plus long - en fut très sophistiqué
voici les grandes tendances de la haute
couture pour cet hiver france hors
france roche qui elle est une véritable
spécialiste en la matière va nous
détailler tout cela puisque nous avons
la chance d'avoir à domicile dans notre
studio donc chez vous un défilé de mode
alors france en dessous du genou à
mi-mollet à la cheville ça se passe
cette année où on veut vous savez la
mode n'est pas une dictature c'est une
proposition il y a des couturiers qui
ont raccourci ya des couturiers qui ont
rallongé
mais dans l'ensemble la mode de
l'austérité est plutôt à la profusion et
la prodigalité d'ailleurs les
sociologues disent que c'est normal
parce que vous savez la mode s'est pas
complètement inutile d'abord c'est un
art
jack lang a fait un musée de la mode de
même signé la veille à new york
ensuite la mode c'est insignifiant
sociologique des gens très sérieux comme
monsieur pierre bourdieu ont expliqué
que la manière dont on s'habillait
signifiait les aspirations les fantasmes
les désirs d'un individu est aussi
soucieux de son époque tout et france
moi j'aime beaucoup vous écouter mais là
j'ai très envie de voir
alors on regarde un petit peu les
modèles et vous nous commenter ça alors
ce sont les robes que j'ai appelé les
robes plus c'est à dire par exemple chez
ferro louis féraud la robe la plus
insolite
alors ils appellent ça une robe de duels
moi je pense qu'il a plutôt rêver qu'un
jour il entrerait à l'académie française
ou alors il a pensé à la mûre sonar
e
chez perse book la plus chaude
alors elle est en vigogne en vous voyez
c'est ce que je vous disais l'austérité
la viola beaucoup de tissus là dedans
c'est une robe de perso quand vigogne
avec la robe gigogne également mais
pailleté chez lanvin la rendre la plus
jeune qu'il arrive on est très tristes
que je dis ça pour la collection est
dédié à la duchesse de windsor
ce film c'est un manteau entièrement en
singe profond on voit jamais ça dans la
rue quand même qu'ils damion merci
restera la haute couture mais la haute
couture elle sert à montrer quand même
les tendances par exemple va y aura
beaucoup de fatigue et éléphants peuvent
aller en voir plusieurs schémas et maury
la plus japonaise voyez ce sont les
cerisiers en fleurs on verra aussi
beaucoup de gris
encore très brandela plus brodés et puis
très hypocrite aussi celle de balmain
vous allez voir les broderies mais sous
les broderies la peau
la plus petite et celle de philippe
venet qui va viser la voilà lors la
fente toujours
ses traits sont moins conséquents nous
élancer transparent si vous regardez
bien
la plus violente et dorante
alors la robe est une espèce de grosse
pleure moi ça coûte une route comme ça à
suivant les maisons ça peut coûter entre
15000 et 20000 francs même allégé même
avec des rabais ses excès d'hier tout à
fait compris dans céret la robe la plus
vendue chez nina ricci un patchwork d'or
et de bleu
scheer ban alors la robe très très très
hypocrite parce qu'elle est à la fois
longues et courtes qu'on puisse cacher
et se montrer c'est tout à fait droit
pour diane dans ce cas on se cache on se
montre encore voilà c'est l'idée et puis
alors la plus courte carrément celle de
courrèges
vous remarquerez les bas de guenilles à
mener pour marco rossi sont innées
derrière
alors à cause de ces dames vous voyez la
couture la haute couture est en pleine
progression 40 % de progression 182
c'est à dire qu'il y avait maintenant
des soins je ne comprends pas du tout
ses robes qui sont très belles superbe
sont très chers on les voit jamais dans
la rue
jamais ou très rarement alors d'avoir
qui va les acheter
et comment cela peut faire vivre
l'industrie puisque c'est quand même des
prototypes et bien d'abord vous avez une
un élément qui a beaucoup servi la haute
couture c'est la dévaluation les
américaines les vénézuéliennes et les
femmes demir se sont dit après tout ça
va devenir intéressante sans notre
shopping à paris et vous savez qu'il
existe certaines femmes des myr et les
émirs en ont plusieurs
qui commande certains modèles en 10
couleurs différentes
alors pour elle convenu de france et pas
très gênant ensuite la couture fait
vivre avec ces accessoires avec les
lunettes avec les ceintures avec les
foulards avec les parapluies avec tout
ça
quarante mille personnes c'est
travailler quarante mille personnes et a
un un chiffre d'affaires annuel de 1
milliard 500 millions dont la haute
couture ne représente que 10%
mais la haute couture c'est c'est le par
avance et c'est le drapeau de toute
cette industrie et la haute couture les
collections en ce moment sont couvertes
pratiquement autant que les jeux
olympiques
qu'est ce que vous avez vu edith cresson
à ses collections non je crois qu'elle
va après avec les clientes mais de tout
faux parce que comme elle aime les
ministres serge hamel oui mais comment s
occupe du commerce extérieur
manifestement c'est un produit qui nous
ramène des devises mais elle est
contente edith cresson je suis si on
peut jouer 4 millions 140 millions en 80
296 millions en 83 40 % de mieux alors
le prêt à porter va s'inspirer de tout
ça il quelle façon le prin porte et s'en
inspire de deux façons la première c'est
que les maisons de haute couture ont
leur prêt à porter alors elles ne vont
pas faire en prêt à porter le contraire
de ce qu'elles ont fait et d'autre part
les petites maisons sont à l'affût de ce
qui va plaire du truc du gag et suivent
la ligne vous savez aller chercher j'ai
bien compris le truc cette année c'est
la fente c'est la pente exactement vous
avez très bien compris après